der gotthard im winter ein stiller und
wenn nicht gerade ein schneesturm tobt
wie in den tagen zuvor weshalb die zwei
talsperren werther ihren kontrollgang
mehrmals verschiedenes
der lago de la selva ist einer der zwei
großen gott hat stauseen 330 meter breit
ist die talsperre 32 meter hoch er baut
ab 1945 als der krieg entschieden war
und das militär hier oben entwarnung
geben konnte
[Musik]
die zwei männer des tessiner
elektrizitätswerkes verschwinden im
innern der stimmung
ein unverrückbares bauwerk es scheint
und doch bewegen sich die betonmassen
jena xiii volumen und temperatur im
millimeterbereich michael buffer und
gianluca mona die kontrollieren ob diese
veränderungen im akzeptablen rahmen
liegen oder ob sie alarm schlagen müssen
[Musik]
nachdem selber setra visieren die männer
einige heikle hänge bei denen kenntnisse
über lawinen gefahren angezeigt sind
der winter hier mit seinen verwehten
schneemassen ist tückisch
auch deshalb ziehen die männer nur zu
zweit auf ihren kontrollgang mehr sorgen
als die betonbauten bereiten im winter
die stromleitung die immer wieder durch
eis und schnee beschädigt werden
die passhöhe liegt in sichtweite
einige anlagen des gotthard kraftwerkes
sind in unscheinbaren gebäuden geradezu
verstärkt diese steinhaus eine alphütte
ähnlich ist ein pumpwerk hier wird das
wasser vom seller in der luciano sehr
hoch gepumpt
testweise schalten die männer die pumpe
ein bevor sie in lange feuchte stoll
eintopf
gott heißt das innerste der schweiz im
winter ein entrückter menschenleerer ort
gelegentlich kommen hier ein paar
skitourengänger vorbei ein trupp
soldaten oder eben die talsperren
werther vom elektrizitätswerk wie ein
findling aus einer anderen welt
der rote container im sommer ein
grillstand bank wird es hier oben mit
der ruhe wieder vorbei sein
[Musik]
der april ist bereits weit
fortgeschritten und auch im urnerischen
hosten tal am fuß des gotthard pass
belegen wird es allmählich zeit für den
frühling
in vier wochen soll die barriere
geöffnet werden
dann wird es für fußgänger auf der
bodanstraße keinen platz mehr haben
die passung das ist seine aufgabe
werner kloos der gotthardstraße meister
und seine männer arbeiten unter
schwierigen bedingungen
die lawinen reste überall in der straße
zeigen es
zwei teams kämpften sich durch den
schnee der passhöhe entgegen eines von
norden her
dieses hier ist auf der südseite und
fern eine arbeit am gleichen berg doch
oft unter äußerst unterschiedlichen
wetterverhältnisse sonne auf der
nordseite nebel hier im süden so ist der
gotthard leben ein berg der
unwägbarkeiten
für mich ist schlimm wie vor sieben
tagen haben die männer unten in airolo
und hosten zahl angefangen noch fast
vier wochen haben sie zeit die
passstrasse zu räumen und für den
verkehr instand zu stellen
genügend zeit so scheint da kann auch
der neuschnee der letzten tage keine
unruhe verursachen
aufgeregt ist hier oben einzig dieses
multi nach dem durchgang der fräse
findet es offenbar seine höhle nicht
mehr das tier hätte wohl besser noch
etwas länger geschlafen
auf der nordseite ist louis baumann
unterwegs der chef der unter http er ist
zuständig für den gotthardtunnel und die
passstrasse die fahrt führt entlang
zahlreicher frischer lawinen auf der
nordseite sind die fräsen bereits weit
in die höhe vorangekommen
wo und wann ist die maschinen warten
können in den tiefschnee vorzudringen
muss rosi müller entscheiden er der
verantwortliche für die sicherheit auf
dieser seite des passes kommt eben von
einer erkundung der lage zurück
der berichtet baumann über die
lawinensituation oft verdrängt die firma
zum training dennoch hat am morgen muss
man die augen beklagt dass das flugzeug
bringt
für die nächsten tage ist regen angesagt
das könnte die situation verschärfen
wer weniger stabil lichttechnik dass sie
den kurznamen abrutscht
aber nicht mehr sind nach rechts auf die
sich dahinter wo mannschaft und sind
richtig genau einen tag später noch hält
sich das sonnige wetter rosi müller
nutzt die gute sicht um mit toni feller
die schneesituation zu prüfen nie verlor
ein bergführer arbeitet für das lawinen
zentrum der armee in andermatt und berät
die schneeräumer am gotthard
in der nacht mit
nicht raus verschiedenen den treffer
rechte bild schnee hat sich auch schon
viele ich denke immer monate positiv ist
schon ziemlich uhr bevor ich weiß nicht
wieso befahren ist mit sprengmeister
region richtig beseitigt sie dass man
etwas gut machen und noch schnell
springen ich rutsche negativ trekstor
über die rechte daten zur drama sondern
in der tank der module das sind ja unter
haben danach heilen und glaube ich werde
jetzt nicht 100 stellen nur zum diät
sowie sony zogen orangen und rund zehn
männer arbeiten gegenwärtig an diesem
park mit seinen lawinengefahr
wie sieht dies der spezialist rüstet was
sie machen
der ski und die möchte damit reich und
insofern bringt sie sich auch vorsichtig
freute sich freuen der morgen früh
abends nachhaltig und es ist kurz vor
sieben uhr morgens in werke von airolo
trifft werner kloos seine mitarbeiter
den brauch mit schnupftabak anzustoßen
hat er von der anderen seite des
gotthards ins tessin gebracht
durch euro verlost bergwärts seine
männer sind in den letzten tagen gut
vorangekommen
es sieht so aus als ob der zeitplan
eingehalten werden könnte hans peter
wyrsch macht seine rolle bei 600 bereit
ein kraftvolles gefährt er gestellt dem
emmental kopiert auch schon in china
schaftlich zu 2.600 tonnen schnee in der
stunde
das hat natürlich seinen preis gegen 400
tausend franken kostet die potente
schneeschleudern
einen kilometer weiter oben verschwindet
die straße im schnee es ist eine
schlüsselstelle bei der schneeräumung
auf der südseite inter der meter hohen
schnee wand versteckt liegt das portal
des feuersturms voraus wollt wie stets
das raupenfahrzeug bereits 30 jahre alt
ist dieses gefährt günstig übernommen
von der schweizer armee
gelegentlich klopft und knallt es
vielleicht ein stein dann müssen die
rotoren neu fixiert werden und dann ist
viel handarbeit angesagt
kampf am gotthard
[Musik]
doch mit der öffnung des tunnel portals
wird nun auch der druck auf den
stärksten meister steigen während news
ist viel unterwegs am berg denn gleich
mehrere baustellen sind zu koordinieren
dabei bewegt er sich durch lawinen land
was man seine frau dazu dass er jeden
morgen aufbricht zu dieser gefährlichen
arbeit hoch gestellt nachdem so berühmt
ja erlaubt
da sie am gotthard selbst in eine lawine
geraten ist darüber möchte er lieber
nicht sprechen
dann gibt es ein problem
rollerfahrer hans peter wyrsch musste
seine fräsarbeiten abbrechen
eine fehlermeldung der maschine zwang
ihn dazu die fräse muss vorerst stehen
bleiben
werner kloos will wissen wie es oberhalb
des tunnels auf dem letzten kilometer
vor der passhöhe aussieht
[Musik]
nicht richtig
doch dann endet die fahrt ohne freese
gibt es hier kein weiterkommen
die schneemenge im tunnel verdeutlicht
mit welcher kraft hier zuweilen der wind
bläst weiter unten am berg schleudert
die roller 600 wieder schnee doch bald
ist arbeitsschluss die temperaturen sind
gestiegen
das schneerutsche auch in die straße
hinein zeigen dass es nun bedrohlich
wird am berg rückzug vom staat
frühmorgens anfang mai noch gut 20 tage
bis zur geplanten eröffnung
nur noch wenige hundert meter sind es
bis zur passhöhe
in kürze werden die männer mit ihren
kollegen zusammentreffen die von norden
her kommt die maschinen werden startklar
gemacht
[Musik]
fast haushoch liegt er oben der schnee
doch wenn die fräse mal den asphalt
freigelegt hat schmilzt der restliche
schnee schnell wände strahlen in einem
nassen glatzmeier sonne ist schon stark
die arbeit im cockpit ist fordernd denn
die schweren maschinen müssen
zentimetergenau geführt werden
ansonsten drohen kollisionen mit dem
felsen oder mit bauteilen am straßen
dann geraten die fräsen von der
nordseite in sicht man könnte nun meinen
das gröbste sei geschafft schon sprechen
einige im unterland davon den pass
früher bereits vor pfingsten zu öffnen
doch die folgenden tage werden einen
anderen zeitplan diktieren überhaupt bis
zur eröffnung sind noch zahlreiche
arbeiten zu erledigen damit diese
bergstrecke auch von flachland
autofahrern befahren werden kann
so müssten sieben kilometer leitplanken
die wegen der lawinen entfernt worden
sind wieder montiert werden oben auf dem
berg macht sich werner kloos auf in den
tiefen schnee vor und rückwärts und
wieder seitlich der gotthard
straßenmeister wirkt wie ein verwirrter
schneeschuhwanderer dabei ist er auf der
suche nach dem unsichtbaren straßenrand
der hospiz ausfahrten eine antenne im
rucksack das gps in der hand so lassen
sich die fixpunkte präzise finden und
mit einer farbmarkierung für die fräsen
sichtbar machen
mittagspause in einem aufenthaltsraum
der tunnelanlage wertlos spricht nun
doch über seinen lawinen erlebnis tricks
ich werde in meiner hand
die spannung in der kita fort und
wertvoller gewiss das aus china geht und
aber das tut schon fragen und ich sage
das ja nicht dass ich das nicht aber es
ist mehr worte möchte wärmen los jetzt
gerade nicht darauf verwenden wollte an
diesem besonderen tag per pass ankunft
kocht der chef eine form der
wertschätzung für seine mitarbeiter
der gott hat
2100 sechs meter über meer
doch als mythische kraft noch viel
mächtiger
einige vermuten hier gar die seele der
schweiz
nun sind die männer also oben
der druck auf eine schnelle öffnung des
passes wird jetzt noch größer werden
es ist diese stelle unweit der passhöhe
wo werner kloos ein jahr zuvor in eine
lawine geraten ist
das ist riesig weiß nicht was los ist
und die dynamische während sich der
deutsche aber das wird einem bewusst das
ist eigentlich passiert ist das ist ja
nicht so dass mir das gesagt ja das hat
man eigentlich gesagt das ist eigentlich
wirklich
oder
halloween ist natürlich alle tot
das ist eigentlich auch den routen von
einer wiener das trägt sie verstehen
das gotthard mattli auf halben weg
zwischen horsten tal und dem hospiz
gelegen
in diesem haus kam vor 70 jahren hans
regel von allen mattli hause genannt zur
welt hier ist er daheim in dieser rauen
windigen gegend und der wind ist in den
letzten jahren immer besser geworden
womöglich eine folge des klimawandels
den winter verbringt hans regli unten in
hospental doch bereits lange vor der
pass eröffnung und dem ersten verkehr
kommt er nach oben vor ostern ist daher
einem einsamen passanten auf dessen
wanderung in den süden begegnet das ist
dann auch noch gar nicht gesagt ich sage
nicht dass glauben ist optimistisch dass
die eu einer auch der weißabgleich mehr
der winter haben wir doch der ton ist
fassen dass sie richtig hunger handeln
das so
heute sind die schneeräumer in scott hat
mattli zum mittagessen eingekehrt es ist
vier tage vor pfingsten und im unterland
spricht man davon den pass bereits dann
zu öffnen
der wird vom gotthard hospiz möchte
wegen der ablehnung gewissheit haben
doch wer mag kann diese nicht bieten er
ist angesichts der wetterprognosen
ohnehin sehr skeptisch dass diese
vorgezogene pass eröffnung klappt und es
ist ja nicht nur der schnee der weg
geräumt werden muss es sind nicht nur
die lawinen die aus den hängen drohen in
den april bergflanken liegen ende winter
lose steine und felsbrocken die auf die
straße stürzen könnten fels räumung
heißt dieser unerlässliche teil der
arbeiten am gotthard
freitag vor pfingsten von der idee den
pass an diesem wochenende zu öffnen ist
man abgekommen
zu eindeutig die wettersituation wären
magnus fährt den berg hoch um zu schauen
ob bei diesem üblen wetter überhaupt
irgendwelche arbeiten an der straße
ausgeführt werden können
oberhalb des kult mattli liegt die
antwort auf der straße metro
räumungsarbeiten ampass wären bei dieser
situation für die männer
lebensgefährlich
es dauert also ich bin guter freund ist
ein schock wenn ich will ja das sind
eingebaut frieden
heute arbeiten die schneeräumer im
werkhof maschinen wo von allen seiten
das wasser ins enge roßtal stürzt
nur eine nacht später ein prachtvoller
frühlingstag erhält die innerschweiz
erfüllen hat die temperatur auf 20 grad
hoch getrieben und vor dem
gotthardtunnel stauen sich die autos an
diesem pfingstsamstag auf einer länge
von 14 kilometern
[Applaus]
dass werner kloos durch den
gotthardtunnel auf die südseite fahren
muss ist ein schlechtes zeichen denn
eigentlich müsste morgen der pass auf
gehen
doch starke schneefälle haben die fahrt
über den berg unmöglich gemacht und dann
geht es auch auf der südseite nicht mehr
weiter eine fräse muss einen weg durch
das meter hohe weiß bahn
dabei löst der weg geschleuderte schnee
unterhalb der straße immer wieder
kleinere lawinen aus
dort wird die fracht während magnus
folgt der fräse im schritt ist ihm klar
geworden dass er wegen der lawinengefahr
heute keine weiteren leute mehr auf der
südseite einsetzen kann
meterhoch liegt eine mächtige lawine
über der passstrasse die vor einigen
tagen bereits geräumte auf einer länge
von 300 metern muss die fräse eine
schlucht durch die schneemassen schaffen
senkrecht über den betritt unter für
werner kloos besteht kein zweifel diese
passstraße kann morgen nicht geöffnet
werden
einen ganzen vormittag benötigt close
für die paar kilometer bis zur passhöhe
von der nordseite her sind bereits die
verantwortlichen der hospiz betriebe
oben angelangt
sie möchten sich auf die angekündigte
morgige eröffnung vorbereiten aus dem
unterland sind die schiffs auf den berg
gekommen
die beratung fällt kurz aus der
entscheid ist eindeutig und auf der
fahrt talwärts findet sich ein weiteres
eindrückliches argument gegen eine
öffnung
dann endlich ist der tag gekommen
vor der barriere oberhalb von airolo
stauen sich schon jene die den gotthard
als erster überquert
es ist jedes jahr ein kleines ritual von
kameras festgehalten
wenn die barrieren zur seite geräumt
werden wenn der gotthard dem winter
entlassen wird und schon bald kommt der
erste gegenverkehr in schneller fahrt
den berg runter
[Musik]
die luft 0 grad die schneewände
erdrückend hoch
für menschen aus dem flachland die auf
sommerpneus hier hinauf gelangt sind
muss die szenerie überwältigend sein
[Musik]
und fast will es scheinen als gehörten
sie nicht hierher
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie ein signal dieser passung denn nun
schmilzt der schnee rasant dahin
[Musik]
und die gotthard royce stürzt krachend
ins tal
[Musik]
im gotthard mattle ist hans regel die
mittlerweile mit all seinen tieren
angezogen
geboren düsseldorf
das recht aber zu bezahlen das sind 20
personen und 50 grad
speziell roth und ich sage das nicht
mehr wichtig wer ist das wichtig daher
dass ich da bin ich geboren
daher sei sie eine schweizweite die
hunde die ohne druck setzen
und auch drohungen und lager hofft auf
ihre figur dafür bieten dass da nicht
rein
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
befolgt das leben heraus rauskaufen 220
volt und miteinanders schon ermutigend
ein trostpreis gab mit der peitsche
ziegler leiter horst hinterfragen
die hybrid
[Applaus]
straßenmeister werner kloos montiert
zusammen mit einem mitarbeiter die
letzten leitplanken
der gdv als arbeitsplatz ein wenig stolz
macht ihnen das schon eigentlich wie wie
brise die landesgrenze bekommt also wenn
die heiligen tote streiche oder weiß und
rot sowie moderator wo sie wie ein
gewitter am
doch das will nichts heißen für den
restlichen tag hier kann das wetter im
handumdrehen wechsel so liegt der granit
so flatterhaft die meteorologie an
diesem berg
[Musik]
elena amelie seit fast 60 jahren
verkauft sie grillwürste und souvenirs
auf dem gotthard damals als
zwölfjähriges mädchen in den schulferien
morgens zu fuß auf von airolo und abends
wieder runter eine freie frau schon
einigen stürmen hat sie hier wieder
standen
aus manchem nebel herausgefunden und
dann diese kundschaft elinor ameli ist
in all den jahrzehnten zur menschen
kennerin geworden seit die schon die die
unis hinter hungriger mittags und ins
integrativ und die italiener die wissen
überhaupt nicht was die möchte in die
diskutieren so viel dann wird man nervös
weil die die eine will deine rote und
der andere den weise und dann und dann
bis denn die nicht weil die trinken
müssen und dann die möchten aber viele
mit viele brot und eine scheibe brot ist
genug und die italiener
wenn man eine kunst die italienische
kundschaft dann man versteht wie die
italien geht's zu viele diskussionen und
nichts überhaupt nichts praktisch nur
bla bla bla und die deutsche wissen ganz
genau was sie wollen und wissen auch was
die bezahlen weil die preise team
geschrieben und die kommen mit dem
richtigem geld in die hände
die verlangen natürlich
[Musik]
euro zurück es ist fast nie ein problem
um dann die holländer sind ganz nett ist
die essen gern was zum beispiel dass wir
wir haben verstanden der niederländer
kam die idee auf die finger weil alles
was die sehen müssen muss das ange
fassen sein
und trotz der amélie flankiert von der
heiligen jungfrau mit klassischer musik
den kalten winden und den eigenheiten
ihrer gruppe
[Musik]
in sichtweite zum hospiz ansonsten
jedoch unberührt vom trubel ist der
gotthard auch eine große anteile
doch selbst zu den sommerlichen
ferienzeiten des hoch betriebes wehrt
sich die passstrasse jeden abend dabei
ist es zu dieser tageszeit hier oben am
erhabensten dann wenn es den anschein
macht als läge die passhöhe noch einige
hundert meter näher beim himmel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bernard gruß der gotthard straßenmeister
muss seine arbeit an diesem berg auch im
sommer schwindelfrei und mit sicherem
tritt nachgehen
aber da habe ich als gbr mit sehr viel
wechsel von himmlischer ruh tierischen
eigentlich wechsel freilich zander und
modern art erinnern und so heuer
zum teil blieben und rentiere natürlich
da hinten drin und für jede oder zum
beispiel irgendwie aber das ist
vermeidbar
zusammen mit einem mitarbeiter ist news
auf der südseite des passes unterwegs wo
weiter bergflanken über der straße mit
lawinenverbauungen und steinschlag
netzen gesichert werden müssen wird
jetzt eilig jetzt bedeute die luft
gesprungen
schwindelfrei sind oder so dollar
gesichert egal ob das lied karaoke-bar
gängig sind und auch für mich ist ganz
klar da muss einfach so passiert hat
sich das risiko noch total erstaunt sagt
michael stich gemacht
tief unten das alltägliche bild der
gestaute ferienverkehr vor dem
autobahntunnel
das diw sieht darin dass das für
verrückt
die fragen und als das trieb natürlich
der war für die spielerinnen das ist
liegt für uns in dem freilich müssen
strahlung
[Musik]
ein sommerlicher hebelte wohl nicht für
lange auf dem gotthard darf man auf die
reinigungskraft des windes vertrauen
[Musik]
stadtleben schwaben steigen schon bald
wieder die rauchzeichen von elena
drummeli in die luft
[Musik]
2 jung hrige pass fahrer sind von diesen
angelockt worden
ja ich bitte dich gar von bugs und setzt
auf wachstum sehr sinnvoll denn das
funktionen aber als eine million
besucher magisch unterhält aber das war
ich glaube dass er mit einem rebreak im
juni wie schon vor 50 gruppen krieg
waren sie über das geschehen
[Musik]
wie eine insel mitten im pass verkehr
das gotthardmassiv doch der verkehrslärm
kann das heimatgefühl von hans regel
nicht trüben
ich möchte ja schon vor dem schlafzimmer
zurück ist ein gangster der wohlklang
daher sind die rennen einfach und es ist
das mit dem bewusst und sie kennen nicht
anders
doch entweder war das ist schon
hinterher jagen der stoff ist daher das
stimmt das keiner sagen das ich je eines
gemischt hat tut man sich doch wie immer
einfach fremd und das nicht sehe doch
und das ist ja das unternehmen uns geld
wenn sie nicht bringt der passt das
nicht
es bringt der post sind
es gibt kaum einen passenderen ort für
eine bundesfeier als der gotthard denn
diese alpenübergang ist für die
entstehung der schweiz bedeutender als
das rütli bedeutender auch als jedes
eidgenössische schlachtfeld um ihn und
die anderen alpenpässe herum haben die
europäischen großmächte 1815 am wiener
kongress die schweiz geformt die kleine
schweiz als neutrale wächterin der
alpenübergänge denn keiner großmacht
wollte mal diese alleine überlassen
für uns ist der gurt nicht nur das herz
der schweiz sondern von ganz europa
vielleicht ich gerade von der ganzen
welt doch bestimmt von europa alle
flüsse kommen von hier der tequila da
hinten die reuss ein wenig weiter weg
die hohen durfte rein
mein vater hat während der ganzen
kriegszeit seinen militärdienst ihr
gemacht hier sind die festungen wo die
schweiz verteidigt wurde lasst uns zum
schluss noch die landeshymne singen
kinder bringen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der gotthard ein schöner berg ist das
nicht keine topographischen
extravaganzen die staunen machen keine
spektakuläre erhöhung die magisch den
himmel berührt doch mit seinen
granitfelsen wird der berg sehr solide
verlässlich schweizerisch spielen
geeignet als letztes stück klein schweiz
das damals vor rund 70 jahren bis zum
schluss verteidigt wurden
bis 1998 war die gotthard festung in
betrieb streng geheim
ein stollensystem von zweieinhalb
kilometer länge heute ist das ein
denkmal von nationaler bedeutung
heute darf man wissen dass hier 420
soldaten ihr letztes gegeben hätten
an vier bunker kanonen und in weiteren
kampf stellung
die bergwiesen sind braun geworden elena
ameli hat sich für ein halbes jahr vom
pass verabschiedet der straßenmeister
als seine maschinen in stellung gebracht
danke fröhlich danken jetzt schon
winterlich nahmen ihren hund
[Musik]
richtige vorwinter stimmiges tag ist
toni calvo brauche nicht bliebe noch
sieben reporter bringen
wenn alles fertig wir haben klar betont
man muss das nach
[Musik]